[Music]
let's lose the other booster and see if
the moon can pull us the rest of the way
casey can we do it
completed
[Music]
get rid of it
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately free bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i needed to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic knocks facing
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
horizon you have got a big gravity
weight coming your way you have to
launch now did he say gravity wave
we're underwater guys
uh that's crazy
[Music]
hang
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
weather
you